[Música]
las drogas de diseño la inteligencia
artificial y el desarrollo en particular
y en general para cambiar el mapa de las
enfermedades durante los próximos años
tal colo como lo conocemos ahora muchas
de las enfermedades que a ustedes le
preocupan en la próxima década van a
comenzar a atenuarse oa desaparecer sin
embargo el progreso va a venir con
cambios en el medio ambiente en el que
habitamos antibióticos sofisticados
esteriliza nuestros intestinos de muchas
de las bacterias detergentes de última
generación limpia en nuestras casas las
dejan libres de polvo el alcohol en gel
le quita las bacterias de las manos a
los chicos cuando vuelves de las plazas
las plazas que llenamos de baldosas a
las que llegamos por calles que eran de
tierra y que ahora hemos pavimentado la
tierra es tan importante para nosotros
como el oxígeno nosotros masticamos
tierra comemos tierra respiramos tierra
y tocamos tierra desde el mismo día que
empezamos a respirar oxígeno el hombre
va a asfixiarse en las próximas décadas
por falta de tierra porque hay moléculas
en la tierra que son importantes para
desarrollar nuestro sistema inmune para
sofisticar nuestro
intestinos para crecer nuestros pulmones
para prevenir las alergias para mejorar
el asma el hombre en su burbuja va a
empezar a ver aparecer enfermedades que
son poco comunes o quizás inexistentes
por haberse divorciado de la tierra así
que la medicina una vez que comience y
termine de festejar haber despejado en
nuestras vidas estas enfermedades que
tanto tememos se va a tener que poner a
buscar tierra
pero lo que tener que hacer de forma
inteligente con la ciencia cuando seamos
todos quienes vivimos hoy y bien el
futuro más ricos y viviendo mejor para
buscar tierra mugre segura kronia para
ricos
[Música]
[Aplausos]